well brief mentions in other videos
about the keyword the encryption and I
work at a company called Righetti
computing we're a company in Berkeley
California and we build quantum
computers from the ground up we do the
silicon fabrication all the way up to
how we program the machines I in
particular think a lot about how we
program the machines how we interface
with it at some point somebody has to
type something into a keyboard to make
it do something and that's mostly where
I think about things quantum computers
really should be thought of as a way to
augment our existing compute
infrastructure exists in computers solve
problems and that's not going away there
they will continue to solve good
problems so a quantum computer really
should be thought of as a is a
special-purpose machine that can solve
certain problems a lot better than
existing computers can solve them in
fact I think thinking of it like a GPU
is is pretty fruitful that GPUs are art
they are computers in a sense but really
they're they're better thought of is
like a coprocessor to your main computer
they GPUs are extremely good at solving
a variety of problems you could sort of
wrangle a GPU to solve any problem you
want to but it's you know regular
computers are good at that so quantum
computers I think of as like on the side
unfortunately current quantum computers
are gigantic they're they you know
they're like the old computers like the
ENIAC they fill a room but nonetheless
you you hook your computer up to this
and it does separate problem-solving as
a company we build these quantum
computers and deploy them there they're
accessible right now on the cloud
there's something that I on my laptop
anywhere actually I don't need any
special interface can connect up to them
and do computations with them and we're
at a point now where the fundamental
unit of resource of a quantum computer
just as we take regular computers and
think about them in terms of bits and
gigabytes and so on on a quantum
computer these are measured in qubits
which are very special because
every time you add a qubit you're you're
doubling the capacity of the computer in
some way so last year we released a
machine that has around eight qubits and
now the current machine we have is about
nineteen qubits so it's not that we
approximately just doubled the qubit
because each qubit itself is doubling so
you have to think of that number of
doublings each time from eight to
nineteen problems that deal with lots of
interactions or lots of possibilities so
to speak our where quantum computer sort
of shine so one big area of application
is in quantum computing is the
simulation of molecules molecules are
are made up of a bunch of atoms and each
of these atoms is is applying a force to
the other atoms they're pushing and
pulling each other and they're just lots
of ways in which the atoms interact with
one another and a quantum computer is
extremely good at keeping track of all
that and dealing with that in a very
efficient way that classical computers
which are normal computers don't deal
with quite as well likewise other types
of problems like optimization which in
mathematics means kind of finding the
best or worst possible solution to a
problem quantum computers are showing a
lot of promise and with that said though
there's one point I want to make which
is sort of in popular science people
think that quantum computers just sort
of try every possibility at the same
time you get all these sort of kooky
interpretations of multiple universes
and so on and quantum computers don't do
that they do not try every possibility
at the same time but the second point is
that applications of quantum computing
is a very active field of research
quantum computers currently are
they're called noisy quantum computers
they they sort of act like analog
devices not digital devices and so
there's all this a little bits of error
and little bits of noise that come into
the system and so it's an active field
of research to see what algorithms and
what problems are very robust to this
noise and it turns out that this
molecular simulation is an example of a
problem that's very robust to noise
whereas what you might heard of like
Shor's algorithm and factoring and
breaking encryption are not robust
annoys at all they're very difficult to
to do so that's a very active field of
research both at the company that I work
at as well as more broadly
the community the sort of room size
computers are sort of where we're at the
way in which these computers have been
constructed is using sort of
off-the-shelf components that have not
been specially made for the construction
of that machine in general so you find
generally with these quantum computers
you find big racks of analog electronics
these electronics that that have existed
for other applications and so it's
definitely not at a point where we've
we've sort of custom fabricated the
entirety of the machine I'm not just
talking about the quantum chip itself
but the thing that the quantum chip is
housed in the electronics that go with
the quantum chip etc etc we're only just
starting we just in general as a in the
field of quantum computation are only
just starting to make like customized
electronics and the like for these
systems the other aspect of this is that
just like the ENIAC for example which
had vacuum tubes that burnt out and you
had to go replace them literal bugs
getting in there and so on neither of
those things happen with quantum
computers but what does happen is that
the system in general isn't shown to be
stable across you know five or ten years
and just hasn't existed that long
and so components are are often swapped
out often changed it's not robust to
changes in the environment like if
somebody walks by with a big magnet the
whole thing kind of goes awry so it's a
really sort of finicky machine not
unlike the early computers like the
ENIAC and so on yeah that is that is
really really far away because we need
to cool these chips down to like the
same temperature or colder than the
temperature of outer space so you need
big refrigerators as they're called not
going to happen for a good while
the interesting thing though is when we
have multiple qubits and this is really
where the power of quantum computation
happens we can actually think of it sort
of simply diagrammatically that if
qubits if I just represent them sort of
as a circle here maybe we have three the
idea is that these qubits can interact
this guy can interact with this guy